this year is the 50th anniversary of the
Alvin it's been in service for science
since 1964 it's only deep diving
submersible in the US
the scientific community decided that
they needed some increased capability
was really a rebuild of the entire
submarine it was an opportunity to see
how scientists and engineers could work
together to solve problems that would
enable them to do science that couldn't
be done the formula
bow to stern the subways disassembled
and reassembled and majority of the
components on the sub especially the
major components like the sphere
brand-new the highest-risk
part of the project was actually the
forging of the titanium sphere because
we built the sphere with the ultimate
objective the vehicle will go to 6,500
meters it had to be able to withstand
pressures at 6,500 metres one of the
requirements was that it be as close to
perfectly spherical as possible it was
forged in Wisconsin into two hemispheres
and then those two hemispheres were
electron beam welded together in
California and an electron beam weld had
never been done on three inch thick
titanium before
one of the really big improvements that
was needed was more viewports with at
least the scientists and the pilot each
having a window with an overlapping
field of view so they could actually see
the same thing and talk about what they
were seeing and the viewports are also
larger and the view is spectacular
so when Elvan goes down it's very quiet
and it's pitch dark except for all this
stuff around you and that's a really
humbling experience to think about sort
of this vast ocean filled with things we
don't know if mr we rarely get to see
them the manipulator arms have been put
on hinged brackets which allows them to
fold out of the way of the viewports but
at the same time it allows them to fold
out forward and in the past you could
describe it kind of like a you know a
t-rex at the refrigerator have these
kind of short arms couldn't get to the
stuff in the in the back these new
shoulder joints you know allow it to
really have an improved reach
I think the wormy discovery and that
really attracted the attention of the
public was Alvin's investigation of the
Titanic
Alvin went back in 86 and actually took
a lot of the imagery that we all now
know
and Alvin is very thankful
it really remains to be seen where
humankind goes with these deep diving
subs there really is nothing like seeing
the environment firsthand
the other nations are building their own
subs such as Japan Russia China and
India and in France I should add so
there's been a lot of talk about the
sort of deep-sea arms race and if
anything all that's doing is pushing the
technology and ve'lo pon these human
occupied vehicles and making it so that
they're more sophisticated and capable
of doing the kinds of science that we'd
like to do
you